and we're going to kick things off with
John hoekstra John is currently vice
president and chief scientist at the
World Wildlife Fund until relatively
recently he had a pretty long stint at
the Nature Conservancy where he was a
senior scientist and where he was one of
the people at TN see who really was
breaking ground in thinking about global
conservation John's also obviously a
master of concise communication there
with his his title but that's that
really speaks very succinctly to what
he's been thinking about over the last
several years and with that I will turn
things over speakers will have 30
minutes to speak and then five minutes
for questions for the first couple talks
and let's welcome John hoekstra thanks
Dave and thanks Walter for having me
here and thank you all for coming out
Walter tried to shoehorn me into some
very narrow subject matter today so
given given the breadth of space that
that title allows me what I thought i
would do today is just share some
thoughts kind of my brief history of
global conservation just look at where I
see the ark having been and where I see
the ark going in terms of global
conservation and do it with a little bit
of an eye towards our topic of spatial
biodiversity science so with that let me
dive in two weeks ago I had the
opportunity to meet Stewart Brand who
was one of the leaders of the
environmental movement really a
generation ago and one of the things
that he's he's famous for is getting
credit for this photograph being
released this is really one of the very
first photos of Earth from space and I
was taken in 1968 and when it was
released to the public it served as a
real kind of a rallying symbol for the
environmental movement it was really the
first time that humans had gotten to see
their planet in that perspective and get
to see it as a whole of course we didn't
really know that much about the planet
back then we were able to see it in a
photograph but
we weren't able to see it in detail from
a scientific and data-driven perspective
but I think that that really kicked off
at least thinking about global
conservation we saw the earth is whole
we had this notion that there was a
global situation in play and I think
that started us on a trajectory after
that one of the things that that came up
and remains vitally important for global
conservation today are red lists so the
IUCN manages the Red List of Threatened
Species this is the compilation of kind
of the names and the status of species
that were worried about going extinct
increasingly has spatial resolution to
it but at the beginning it really was a
list this trend in data aggregation
continued and this is the theme I guess
of the early parts of global
conservation was really going from that
first picture to aggregating data about
the state of the world and an important
moment came when Eric dinner Steen and
other colleagues that World Wildlife
Fund delineated the terrestrial
ecoregions of the world this reflected a
really grand compilation of data about
the ecological systems the communities
of species and they delineate it
essentially these ecological
neighborhoods of the world and it gave
us for the first time a framework around
which to organize global conservation so
instead of having to rely on political
boundaries for which nature is happily
ignorant and pays no attention we now
have some ecological neighborhoods that
do have some meaning for nature and it
gives us a powerful framework for
organizing our thinking organizing our
science around global conservation and
that led to an explosion of global
prioritization efforts so this is from a
2006 paper by Tom Brooks and colleagues
at Conservation International but these
are nine different kind of independently
derived global prioritization schemes
the one top Center biodiversity hotspots
is the one that Conservation
International is famous for it reflects
places in the world where there are lots
and lots of endemic plants
species and there's been lots of habitat
loss 1,500 plant species per region and
more than seventy percent habitat loss
the upper left our crisis ecoregions
that was the paper I was involved with
those are places where habitat loss is
high and habitat protection is low and
one would therefore be worried about the
ecological systems unraveling just other
examples frontier forest bottom middle
these are kind of the last in the sorry
last of the wild and this lower right
these are kind of the biggest expanses
of habitat representing each biome in
each realm of the world so all these are
different schemes that reflect data that
were compiled by various NGOs with
academic partners on the richness of
species on the rarity of species on the
uniqueness of the communities of species
etc and depending on the values that
were applied the criteria that were
chosen by the different organizations we
generated this amazing diversity of
prioritization schemes which in
aggregate represent about eighty percent
of the world underscoring the fact that
depending on who you ask their part of
the world is generally going to be
considered important to them but this
was a big deal in in global conservation
and pretty much every big conservation
organization had a map built a map use
that to sort of establish their their
scientific bona fide ease it was it
excite it was an exciting time but it
was just it was very selective outtakes
so then then an interesting thing
started to happen and I'm going to be a
little self-serving in this regard a
couple years ago several colleagues at
the Nature Conservancy and I published
this book the atlas of global
conservation the second author gen moun
r is a Yale alum work with Dave skelly
this book reflects the science of the
Nature Conservancy used to figure out
its global priorities so my job at TNC
was to help them figure out where they
should be working around the world what
their mobile priorities should look like
we made that crisis ego regions map
although that didn't get stamped as the
prior
already set but rather we gathered up
lots of information that was provided to
decision-makers and they made a variety
of decisions internally but we realized
that we had compiled this amazing
collection of data we work with more
than 70 institutions around the world to
gather more than 100 global data sets
about where biodiversity was distributed
what its status was what threats how
threats were distributed around the
world and how conservation was being
allocated around the world and rather
than try to process it into an answer we
thought wouldn't it be great to put it
out there so we published this book
which two years later feels rather
antiquated to be honnest because all
this stuff has gone digital I think next
we're going to hear from Walter about
the map of Life Project which is an
example of how these kinds of global
data sets are really coming to life and
we saw talks earlier today that
reflected the same but in this kind of
first sweep of global conservation what
I what I saw was lots of effort in data
aggregation and developing these
pictures of the state of the world we
then entered in the last few years as
kind of a middle phase that to me from a
science and data perspective is about
using all these aggregated data and
starting to process it starting to
juxtapose it in interesting ways to
reveal new insights into some of the
challenges and the solutions for
conservation one of the trends that was
happening in global conservation at the
time was a scaling up seeking to
undertake ever larger and larger project
so that ecoregion framework that eric
interesting help draw out gave us a way
to imagine wow we don't want to just
conserve a place here in a place there
we want to conserve entire regions and
so people started to imagine projects
like the Great Bear Rainforest which is
protecting 25 million acres along the
coast of British Columbia or the Coral
Triangle initiative that's trying to
span across six countries and protect
the world's most diverse quarrel region
so this is a figure from a paper out of
Paul arms worth lab at 10 in Tennessee
and a lot of attention has been paid on
the left this is fee
simple habitat acquisition in the US on
the right its conservation easements if
you like the details it's time along the
x axis it's logarithmic size on the Y so
if you just follow the top line on that
figure sorry let me use my laser pointer
instead of my finger if you just follow
the top line of this spread there has
been a really significant increase from
a hundred hectares to 10,000 hectares to
a million hectares in size so
conservation has been undertaking larger
and larger and larger projects and
that's been a big theme in global
conservation but remember that that
spread is really large there's no
shortage of small conservation efforts
still out there another trend in in
thinking about global conservation using
these data was to start to juxtapose
kind of the biodiversity information
with information on things like cost and
think about conservation return on
investment so this is a paper by bill
murdock and company looking just at
argentine grasslands as a case and and
they combine data about what sorts of
biodiversity you'd protect if you picked
different locations across argentina but
they also factored in costs and so this
is just a nice figure that shows three
different ways of approaching
conservation priorities on the left if
you try to just maximize benefits that's
the classic just go where the species
richness is higher kind of approach no
matter what the cost you get this kind
of distribution all these little blue
dots scattered around Argentina that's
what you would protect if you wanted to
just maximize benefit without respect to
cost if you wanted to just be cheap and
minimize the cost of conservation you'd
go and you buy up a big chunk of habitat
that must be the least desirable real
estate in Argentina but you'd go there
and then if you're if you're clever as
or as few passing would stay not stupid
Hugh passing him would call you not
stupid by doing this you use return on
investment and you would take a ratio in
there different algorithms for taking a
ratio of the benefit you get in the cost
that you impose and you get a third very
different sort of
allocation of resources and a different
picture of conservation and there's a
lot of interesting work by Hugh passing
and by bill murdock and others factoring
in this cost factor and I think again
this is kind of this middle trend in
global conservation trying to figure out
how do we take this limited pool of
money that we will always have this is
going to be limited pool and how do we
make the most of it a third trend that
that's started to come up in the last
few years is juxtaposing biodiversity
information with other sorts of data
related to human interests economic
benefits or ecosystem services so this
is a clip out of a recent paper by Will
Turner at Conservation International and
the top panel is an index of ecosystem
service value it reflects water
pollination soil carbon and carbon
factors heavily in the distribution of
colors here yellow is is greater
ecosystem service value blue is less and
then juxtapose that with the level of
threatened endemism so as an index of
conservation value in a biological sense
they mapped what's the percentage of
threatened species that are endemic and
in the next opposed and they play the
little statistical games about how much
benefit to people you'll get if you can
serve things for biodiversity and you
could imagine playing it the other way
so there's been a lot of energy around
starting to link up conservation and
other sorts of human centered values in
the last trend that I've started to see
in global conservation is really paying
attention to climate change so this is a
figure that the Audubon Society put out
through the associated press they had a
report on birds and climate change in
North America and this figure uses
Christmas Bird Count data to measure the
shift in winter ranges of a number of
species so the way you look at it here's
the Roofus cited toki which dot is that
i think it might be this one it's kind
of centered winter center of gravity
used to be here in Arkansas and now it's
over here in western Kansas the Virginia
rail is moved from New Mexico up to Utah
sellers j from Oregon to Washington etc
so we're starting to see global
conservation go from to me this figure
has two meanings one we're going from
sort of static mapping of how
biodiversity is distributed and
comparing it to things like cost and
human benefits and the like a lot of
static mapping to now we're starting to
ask how biodiversity is changing as a
function of climate change so I think
it's very very important in that to me
shifts us into into where global
conservation is heading climate change
is going to be something that global
conservation is going to have to wrestle
with economic development is going to
have to wrestle with humanitarian aid is
going to have to wrestle with human
health is going to have to wrestle with
so it's very important that we start
paying attention to it and we're going
to actually need to do more than just
understand how biodiversity might move
around as a result of climate change
we're going to have to start really
confronting issues of how do we mitigate
climate change through things like
preventing an avoiding deforestation
changing our energy consumption we're
also have to think about adaptation so
maybe this isn't a big deal in fact when
I first googled looking for this image
it was in a skeptics blog who was trying
to call out that hey a lot of these
species are actually doing quite well
that's actually fine but we're gonna
have to pay attention to is we need to
know not only how things are moving how
are they changing in abundance and what
sorts of adaptation interventions might
that require from a conservation
perspective if they're linkages between
biodiversity and human benefits in
climate changes shifting the
productivity of those systems what is
that going to mean from adaptation
perspective of things like sea level
rise are causing people to move inland
what kind of ramifications is that going
to have etc so we're going to need to
really be paying attention to
biodiversity data in a much more dynamic
sense in the future so that we can be
detecting and using our understanding of
change to modify our conservation
interventions another tidbit about data
that i think is forthcoming and actually
felt badly having this in my
presentation after having the cycle of
pd of life in ybor
presentations much better examples of
what I wanted to make at this point this
is a clip from websites called moabi
this is an application that World
Wildlife Fund has developed and the
purpose of it is to create a mobile
based social network platform for
citizens to monitor deforestation legal
and illegal in the Democratic Republic
of Congo so the idea here is that
there's a lot of stuff that we can do in
terms of satellite monitoring and such
with forests but you also need boots on
the ground and conservation groups will
never have as many boots on the ground
as just communities will and so we're
trying to empower these communities to
be part of their own monitoring so moabi
is meant to be a platform that allows it
sort of democratization of data and so
this is where this history of
aggregation which was great for all of
us scientists that like to crunch those
numbers now needs to turn to a future of
disaggregation where we want to gather
to information together and then be able
to deploy it out and I think you know II
bird is a great example of the power
that we saw in the talk this morning of
the aggregation part of the data but but
then I've also goes wrong pocket they've
got to mikes on me today on my phone I
have an eye bird app that taps into the
e bird system and so you know I can hop
on here and find out what birds have
been seen around Yale in the last couple
weeks that's terrific that sort of
disaggregation of data out to users in a
format that they're interested in in
real time that sort of power i think is
going to be really important for global
conservation in the future as more and
more people want to tap into global
perspectives even as they continue to
make local interventions
I mean so now let me turn into a little
bit more of an unknown future one of the
things we're going to be confronting in
the coming decades so 40 years ago we
got our first look at the world hole
today we can see it in pretty remarkable
detail thanks to satellites thank the
sorts of data aggregation efforts that
we've undertaken 40 years from now we
are going to have to have solved some
really profound problems and so this
figure is meant to highlight those the
Green Line is kind of where we're at
just in a unit way by 2050 we're going
to add two billion people to the planet
mas o menos we're going to need to
increase food production by seventy
percent we're going to need to increase
or meet energy demands that are expected
to grow 45 maybe even fifty percent and
we're going to have to somehow meet
water demands that are gonna grow by
fifty five percent these are really
profound challenges again not just for
conservation but for development for
humanitarian interest for health
interests etc so in one generation we've
gone from really being able to see the
earth for the first time we've got only
40 wild like we've got 38 years less
than 40 years to figure out how we're
all going to live on this planet how
we're going to take as much nature with
us as possible so I put that up there
just to underscore the nature of that
challenge and it's going to be a
challenge that brings forward issues of
resource scarcity and again this is
going to this is going to go beyond the
conservation circles which I actually
think is a good thing so it's no longer
going to be us sort of lonely waving the
flag of hey we're losing things on the
planet shouldn't society get behind us
and help save it it's all going to
become a lot more real when it has to do
with food water and energy energy people
are going to find some interest there
and we have an opportunity to find
common ground to work out how are we
going to bring nature along through
what's going to be a pretty tight
bottleneck on this planet the next 38
years and it's going to change our
picture so think back to that ecoregions
map that was a really beautiful map that
by the
way it was colored made you think of it
was meant to represent kind of all the
great Nature you find all over the world
every single part of the land was
covered there are actually also
freshwater ecoregion and marine
ecoregion so we painted this picture in
conservation that was sort of wall the
wall nature but the reality is that it's
not wall-to-wall nature we saw again in
the e bird one of those videos i love
that you could see city centers where
the birds weren't that was really cool
it's not while the wall nature and again
this image is meant to remind us of that
these are the anthropogenic biomes so
instead of having tundra and temperate
forests and temperate grasslands and
tropical forests which sort of
underpinned the ecoregions map this is a
map that naveen ramen cudi developed
with some colleagues these are the
anthropogenic biomes and we have wild
lens over here in the upper right these
sort of nice pale green colors that show
up in the high latitudes we've got
forests in the green and rangelands then
sort of tan but then all suddenly get
into croplands villages and urban
settings and there's a lot of those kind
of left hand colors on the world today
and so i think it's going to be
interesting to take the biodiversity
information we have the spatial data we
have and begin to understand how much
biodiversity goes with some of these
totally new kinds of systems that are
out there and can we manage those
systems in a way that they keep as much
biodiversity as possible so even though
the world is going to look like this
from a delineation perspective you can
we layer in as much biodiversity as
possible so up close just with some
other few other remarks that I hope will
be a little bit provocative and spur
some questions and discussion with the
rest of our our time and and that is
that we're at a moment that I call the
pivot for global conservation and the
pivot tap is playing out over a few
years but it is a moment I think where
we're moving from a field that
essentially looked backwards to a past
state that we are quite confident up
hence the ! so we would look back maybe
was 18 50 maybe was 1900
1700s but we would look backwards to a
previous state that we could document
through historical records say that's
what we should have we're now pivoting
to a much more forward-looking posture
and conservation and we're looking into
a very uncertain future we know that
things are changing we know where to
more people we're going to have fewer
resources we're losing biodiversity
climate is changing all around us so we
don't know how that's going to play out
but it's going to challenge us to think
about how are we going to shape that
future we have entered the Anthropocene
it is going to be a geological era
defined by people and the good news is
that we are those people so we have we
have a chance to shape this era and and
that's what I think conservation is big
challenges in this pivot and so it's
going to challenge us to become
forward-looking because we don't know
exactly where we're going we don't know
exactly what the world is going to look
like we're going to shift from thinking
about what to conserve and where to
conserve as our priorities and we're
going to think about how to conserve so
we're going to start prioritizing the
problems what are the big challenges in
front of us and I think they're going to
have to do with confronting resource
scarcity how are we going to feed water
and fuel nine billion people and still
take a lot of conservation along with us
start breaking that down those are going
to be the challenges that we need to
confront as opposed to here are hot
spots here of global 200 ecoregions
we're also going to need to start
thinking about nature and thinking about
conservation of nature in a much more
dynamic way so again we can't we can't
just use some historic State a snapshot
of the past as our benchmark that we're
trying to go back to we're going to have
to be trying to create a system that's
going to be moving underneath our feet
so between the activities of people
across the planet and climate change
we're on kind of unsteady footing and
we're going to have to use every bit of
science we can to understand how things
are changing stay on our toes be nimble
and be dynamically adjusting our
conservation where again to carry as
much biodiversity with us into the
future we're also going to I think be
challenged to evaluate our work not in
terms of what we have
it lost but in terms of the kind of the
outcomes we've really achieved so it may
be a wonky point but I think
conservation is going to be challenged
to not just say hey that was great this
species didn't go extinct yet which is
usually how we play to our next round of
funding but I think we're going to have
to say here's a problem we're going to
help solve it here's the intervention
that we took here's the outcomes that we
achieve and those outcomes are going to
have to be both in terms of the
biodiversity that we've helped secure
and keep healthy and productive and
abundant but also in the benefits that
we deliver to people when they're
expecting some sort of mutualism there
and then two more points touched on this
already I think that this future is
going to push conservation squarely to
an intersection with business with
humanitarian interest with development
interests with health interests and to
me that's a really exciting thing so the
days of saving conservation from nature
over this saving nature for people is
not meant to be like a fuzzy we're all
now in it for people and we're not in it
for nature thing anymore but I think
it's going to it's really going to rest
on this issue of how do we maintain a
planet that is productive enough to feed
nine billion people that sustains the
sort of natural systems that we need to
provide clean water productive soils
healthy fisheries etc so i think that
conservation has a real role to play and
we need to start spelling that out like
what is the role of conservation for the
future of the planet and the needs of
people that they're going to be trying
to meet and then last I think that we're
going to go from that sense that
conservation was getting bigger and
bigger and bigger in terms of that
scaling up I think if you think back to
that figure from Paul arms worth paper
there is lots there will always be lots
of kind of small conservation if you
will I think that the global the future
of global conservation is going to be in
achieving global impact through
distributed interventions and that's
what I think the kind of the
democratization the disaggregation of
data is going to be really really
important because we need to go from
having a relatively limited number of
conservation groups doing their
damnedest to do what they can for the
anat we are going to need to rebuild an
environmental movement that is waning
rebuild it so that more and more people
whether because they care about nature
because they care about some other
interests that nature helps support
their out helping protect it in their
communities we need to make sure they
have the science they need that includes
businesses that are right now very much
aware of the resource scarcity issues
they're worried about it for their
future competitiveness they're worried
about it for their future viability in
business and so there is a window for us
to take conservation science into some
whole new arenas and help answer that ?
of what's that future going to look like
40 years from now so I'll stop there and
welcome some questions
so Jonathan has been a moderators dream
and there's plenty of time for questions
so I think I know the answer to this one
I'm quite curious SAS the food duction
has to go act like said wow population
in shreds up by this is the ways that
disparity yeah disparity comes from more
of the 7 billion people that we have
today and the 9 billion people were
going to have in a few years wanting to
live like you and I it's change in diet
is to change in consumption as we bring
more and more people out of poverty
they're going to want to eat more food
and they're going to want to eat more
meat and that's going to drive the
production
life's not easy yeah absolutely yeah
that sounds really popular edition I
firmly created that first ruckus
two key issue for globally and naturally
and wonder I didn't hear excessively a
deep mention of because it's
conservatives for decision support tools
that could support your local
decision-making or more regional making
or clinch
what I see is you were looking for that
purpose of all of you go I think nothing
stupid yeah what is there to the working
at system of decision support this is
Tennessee I think you're going to see a
lot of it actually makes me think of as
an admission in terms of thinking of
adding that into the debt this thing's
like the natural capital project its
standard of the University of Michigan
building pools that frame up ecosystem
service trade-offs between different
development options you can make that
spatially explicit you can start to link
that data is a big driver there in terms
of how precise you can be that's an
example there are in the business sector
where businesses that depend on water
that depend on agricultural commodities
are starting to recognize hey the
world's fine it out there we need to
make sure that we have a secure supply
chain if we want to stay in business
they're starting to think about is
driving sectors and ethan palm oil soy
to think about voluntarily adopted
standards sustainability and in terms of
how they produce their commodities and
one of the things they factor in our
high conservation value areas which is
turns out as wickedly hard to map and
come to terms with because if you think
back to that list of all those different
global priorities you've got to go
reconcile all those different values of
what's important but the question is
being asked what are the places that we
should protect because of their
conservation value what are the places
we should protect because of their
ecosystem services value questions being
asked so we have a tremendous
opportunity to be answering it and
Justin decision support tools tailored
to those groups are going to be part and
parcel with it time for one more
question
but following up on that you had thee
was it nine maps of the global
priorities what happens if you combine
all nine and you show you show the ones
that you showin read everything that
appears on all night and then you go
down through your colors do you get to
the ones that appear only on one what
happens when you aggregate that way what
does it look like you still end up with
a lot of the world colored and in the
tussle over over whose values should
reign supreme so I don't have that I
don't have this slide in my deck but I
think Tom even did this in this in this
paper they lumped it up so there are
some places that come out they come out
as really iconic places like the Amazon
like Indonesia like the Congo Basin you
can just kind of eyeball it they come
out as some of the really iconic
biodiverse places in the world so that's
not too surprising but I think that if
you actually limited conservation to
those areas we would first of all lose
huge amounts of biodiversity in the rest
of the world and we would probably
undermine a lot of the services that
people that live in lots of those other
places depend on so I personally don't
find it all that instructive even though
I contributed to one of these maps I
think that this is not what we need to
pay attention to in the future we really
need to figure out somebody lives in
almost all those places and they're
going to care about it we need to help
them figure out how to conserve those
places as best they can whether it's one
of my priorities one of your priorities
are someone else's priorities
very interesting about the
democratization of these efforts and
cell phones so if people are up you know
what what is the incentive for people to
keep uploading information and to whom
are they are promoting it and what is
done with it when it's uploaded and it
does moabi have answers to all those
questions how does this work yeah and
it's natural real way forward isn't real
way forward what we're struggling with
with miyabi quite frankly is how do we
bring value to the users on the cell
phone end so that they've got the
incentive to put something up there and
how do we reflect their data back to
them in a way that adds to that I think
you know ebird to me is a great example
of getting on the right page with
burgers I love it cuz I pull it up see
what's burning so it's giving me some
value that really has nothing to do with
the analyses that Steve showed us but it
enables those analyses by creating the
incentives I think that's the challenge
the health sector is doing the same
thing I'm going to a meeting in a month
and a half to talk about how this same
kind of technology is going to getting
applied in the health sector so I think
we're gonna we're going to be able to
learn some lessons and maybe draw on
those but it's all going to be about
providing value and adding value to
people to contribute and come back but I
figure if people are willing to write
reviews on Amazon and there's loads of
examples of people we will need to put
information for because they're getting
something valuable back we need to tap
into that I think yep thank you all very
much and be happy to take some more
questions over the cocktails